today the brewer is playing against the
detroit tigers with bill schroeder and
sofia minute jeff levering with you the
roof is open brewer is trying to make it
five in a row today this is lieutenant
general cardler's first pitch the
wind-up good form he was all worried
he's a former pitcher he pitched for
brewer's official score tim o'driscoll
at arrowhead high school look at that
even the follow through
this is corbin burns looking for some
run support here yeah the brewers oddly
enough have only won two of his starts i
mean the numbers and the record really
doesn't jive two and four
and he starts out with a strikeout he
gets robbie grossman
out number one to open up the ball game
for corbin burns yeah the tigers they
will strike out quite a bit as an
offense third most in the american
league there's that cutter one-two
side corner offering a brilliant start
for corbin burns
a couple of strikeouts and the flawless
first
second and third one away 3-2 pitch to
badou
just missed again off the outside corner
base is loaded now for detroit
and the number eight hitter jake rogers
at the plate bondu over there at first
after drawing the walk with one out
again looking for a strikeout
alexander is on deck
1-2
struck him out
back-to-back cutters to get him
took the first
and swung through the second one that
one pretty much down the middle got away
with it
and now
we will see a pinch hitter alexander was
on deck
mazara who looked like he was going to
be a star when he first emerged with the
texas rangers
back in 2016. one strike on mazzara
roller to first casting here is got it
and corbin burns gets out of the bases
loaded jab big strike out in the ground
up
to third ureas had it eat him up
able to get it back throws high here
able to get back down on the bag nice
play casting here to go up tall yeah a
couple of shaky toes by erase over at
third base
casting able to show a good vertical
lead
able to come down with it foot on the
bag before
scope got to first
see that arm drops
and by the time it gets to kessinger
he's able to grab it get the foot on the
bag and get the out throw like that rock
sometimes you'll see the first baseman
instead of trying to fall back down on
the bag try and swipe that arm one and
two on victor reyes and a swing in the
midst of the curveball narvaez blocked
it another strikeout for corbin burns so
it's only two
and he came up empty
for the folks that say there should be a
universal designated hitter that is the
video that they should show right but
not a brewers hitters
blind and caught by hira touches the bag
a double play
grossman hit it on the screws casting
here right place right time an easy
double play to get burns
out of the fifth there's jonathan scope
who singled his first time he needs to
find a hole here catch a break he got
the runner 90 feet away at third base
scoreless ball game so far now you want
to look for something out over the plate
because that's where he wants to go the
payoff
on the inner part of the plate strokes
one to deep left field that ball is
foul
aj's maybe gonna just ask for a replay
this ball might be hit
over the foul pole of fair pole
depending on what you like calling it
boy see when it's up over the top of the
pole it's a lot harder to call is it
did it hook around it
we know where it landed it landed foul
bubble
yeah
he's not willing to throw the change up
or the cur or the curveball another
three two so you you sit right yank to
the left is that a fair ball no that's a
foul
ball he can almost eliminate the the
curveball or anything off speed here he
just doesn't have the courage to throw
at 3-2 with a runner 90 feet
away clearly fall
there you go stroke to center in an rbi
single
for jonathan scope and the tigers score
first here in milwaukee what an at-bat
for scope and he gets rewarded with a
ribby
so good to see here he gets the ball out
over the plate it's the cutter you can
see the spin see that small circle
that's the cutter but he leaves it down
over the middle and after seeing about
four or five pitches that were at the
same speed
jonathan puts the barrel to it the
tigers take the lead in the sixth
to william
one out runner at first
brewers down one nothing
[Music]
three two
fly ball right field well struck back
track wall brewers lead it two to one
really adamas goes oppo
a lot of energy doesn't he
i finally got one of those fastballs and
he hit it a ton to the opposite field
claws up
yeah in some
aspects we're lucky to have burns out of
the game before trailing by a run but
dude storms into one deep right field
and we are tied
that's the answer you're looking for and
it comes here to lead off the seventh
well good for akil badu here's a kid
that has been more and more patient
he went through some real tough
at-bats
see the pitch it's a change-up
that's a pitch that has given him
trouble but this one stays up
and look at the focus he has on the
hands stay back he pulls him in and then
just barrels it up
shallow center
out goes urias in the shift here comes
kane to make the catch throw to first
not in time
and no chance for wong he went out there
a long way but not able to get there i
think kane
might have called him off right at the
last moment yeah i think i said wong it
was arias going out there i think
lorenzo called him off he peeled off and
kane able to make the catch
after making that catch never went out
to center field dave yeager came out to
check on him and watch lorenzo as he's
making this catch
makes a little leap and then lands
firmly
on his right leg and lorenzo just kept
on running
and started grabbing at the back of his
right leg
decent lead for travis
ground ball left side knocked down by
candelario gets up throws to first in
time and we are going to extra innings
for the second straight game here at
american family field sanjira will lead
it off at the plate with omar narvaez
standing at second base
see if kesten here tries to lay down a
bun tigers playing like he will and he
does perfect buck from kesten hero
hits the sacrifice done
a beauty winning run at third base
louise urias
chance to deliver his first walk-off hit
another one-two pitch on its way to luis
urias
fly down right center field that should
be well deep enough
reyes can't catch up it bounces on the
warning track and over the wall the
brewers are going to win it in ten
innings it's luis arias on this memorial
day a great battle by the brewers third
baseman at the plate with jose cisnero
and he got it out there plenty deep yeah
just tried to put the bat on the
baseball and
hit it deep into right center his first
walk off hit
in his career
louisa he knew it as soon as you made
contact it was deep enough but better
yet gets the base hit
and the brewers win a thriller here
today
a great ball game a great crowd today to
celebrate it brewers have won five in a
row